but in the intellectual domain compound
interest rules let's talk about compound
interest compound interest most of you
should know it in the finance context if
you don't then you know crack open a
microeconomics textbook it's worth
reading microeconomics textbook through
from uh you know start to finish
macro economics you can skip for the
most part uh as nassim taleb says it is
much easier to macro than it is
to micro so with macroeconomics
there's just so much politics that
bleeds into macroeconomics especially
once you're beyond the basics of supply
and demand that's very hard to tell when
you're reading politics with a little
bit of mathematics around it and when
you're actually reading something that's
more fundamental
so compound interest is basically the
idea that let's say if you're earning 10
a year the first year you make 10 and
you end up with let's say you had a
dollar you invested you end up with a
dollar 10. but the next year you end up
with a dollar 21 and the next year you
end up with a dollar 32 or 33. so it
keeps adding on itself in such a way
that if you're compounding at 30 a year
for 30 years
you don't just end up with you know 10
or 20 times your money you end up with
thousands of times your money so
compound interest is a very powerful
concept but compound interest applies to
more than just compounding capital uh
compounding capital uh is just it's just
the beginning compounding business
relationships is very important if you
look at some of the top roles in society
like why does someone get to be a ceo or
public company or be on the board of a
public company or why does someone get
to be a banker who's managing a billion
dollars is because people trust them and
they trust them because the relationship
in which they've worked the work they've
done it's kind of compounded they've
stuck with the business and they've
shown themselves in a visible and
accountable way to be high integrity
people so compound interest can also
happen in your reputation if you have a
sterling reputation and you do a good
job with it and you keep doing that for
decades upon decades people will notice
that and your reputation will literally
end up being thousands to tens of
thousands of times as valuable as
somebody else who is actually very
talented but is not
keeping a
kind of compound interest game and
reputation going
this is also true when you're working
with
individual people so if you've worked
with somebody
at in a business where they're your
co-worker and you work together for five
or ten years and you still enjoy working
with them obviously you trust them the
little foibles are gone all the
negotiations
that normally would happen to business
relationships can work very very simply
because you just trust each other you
know it'll work out
for example there's another angel in
silicon valley uh eli gill who i like to
do deals with and the reason i love
working with illah is because i know
that when the deal is being done he will
bend over backwards to give me extra he
will always round off in my favor if
there's an extra dollar being delivered
here or there if there's some cost to
pay uh he'll pay it out of his own
pocket and he won't even mention it to
me and because he goes so far out of his
way to treat me so well i send him every
deal that i have i try and include him
in everything and then i go out of my
way to try and pay for him
so that relationship just ends up so
powerful that the oneplus one is more
than two as investors here
so compounding in those relationships is
is very valuable even like fitness and
health many of you have probably been on
various diets and nutrition programs and
exercise programs and you probably
noticed that it takes a little while
before you kind of go through these
growth spurts and then once you've gone
through a spurt you kind of landed a new
level either you're thinner or you're
more muscular and then you can jump up
to the next level from there obviously
fitness we're talking about
physiological compound interest is not
going to work anywhere near as strongly
as it will in the purely intellectual
domain but in the intellectual domain
compound interest rules
even when you look at a business a
business that may have a hundred users
but is growing at a compound rate of 20
per month will very very quickly stack
up to having millions of users and
sometimes even the founders of companies
are surprised by how large the business
scales so when you find the right thing
to do when you find the right people to
work with
then just investing deeply into that and
sticking with it for decades is really
how you make the big bucks and you make
the big returns in your relationships
so compound interest is very important
[Music]
you